[Musique]
la commanderie continue son exploration
des arts visuels du corps du mouvement
pour sa nouvelle exposition le site
saint quentinois a donné carte blanche
un photographe qu'est ce qui vous a plu
mélanie la simplicité des photos alors
simplicité dans le bon sens du terme
elle est apparente allez le voir dan
ramène c'est le photographe exposé qui a
capturé le mouvement 26 clichés née
d'une carte blanche comme vous l'avez
dit gregory pendant un an
l'artiste nordiste est allé à la
rencontre des corps surtout décor
artistique il a photographié des
danseurs des circassiens le résultat de
son travail des nets des flous une
impression de vie comme si les danseurs
des artistes à l'équité à les clichés
pour danser devant le spectateur et les
artistes photographier ne sont pas
inconnu des amateurs de culture à saint
quentin
et oui puisque le dal ramène s'est
attaché à des compagnies en résidence ou
en représentation sur le territoire on y
retrouve christian et françois ben aïm
la compagnie masala deux fois de
boussouf ou encore la compagnie la main
de l'homme de clément d'azun le travail
s'est fait avec la mission dense de
l'agglomération des précisions et cofely
petit la responsable des arts visuels de
la commanderie
l'idée c'était de croiser aussi les
artistes que nous programmons et puis
les rencontres se font ne se font pas et
là ça c'est fait il se trouve que notre
partenariat avec la mission danse ça a
été de faire qu'ils puissent rencontrer
des chorégraphes donc il a rencontré
plusieurs chorégraphies la assister à
plusieurs spectacles et pour découvrir
tout cela memento corpus et a exposé à
la commanderie des templiers jusqu'au 10
mars
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans un
instant pour votre émission le 7-8
culture avec d'autres informations
d'autres expositions également à
découvrir sur le territoire